الملكة ليست زعيمة سياسية ،
لذا فهي أقل إثارة للانقسام ، أضف إلى ذلك
سجلها كأطول
رئيس دولة في
العالم وفازت بمنصبها في
وسط الصورة العائلية
، حيث خرج أفراد العائلة المالكة بقوة في كورنوال
يوم الجمعة
بدءًا من  زيارة مشتركة إلى المدرسة من
قبل دوقة كامبريدج
والسيدة الأولى نفسها ، وهي معلمة ، وهي
الصف الأكثر هدوءًا ، وقد
كان الأطفال حريصون على التباهي
بحيواناتهم الأليفة والدوقة حريصة على التحدث إلى حيواناتها الأليفة
بشأن قضية رفاهية الأطفال أثناء
مناقشة مع
خبراء التعلم البريطانيون والأمريكيون يعتبر التعليم في مرحلة
الطفولة
المبكرة أمرًا مهمًا للغاية
لأن أفضل استثمار لصحتنا وسعادتنا في المستقبل
يكمن في السنوات الخمس الأولى من الحياة.
ليليبيت طفل ميغان الجديد ،
أتمنى لها كل التوفيق ، لا أطيق
الانتظار لمقابلتها
لأننا لم نلتقي بها
بعد ، لذا
آمل أن يكون ذلك قريبًا
في هذه الأثناء ، سُئلت السيدة الأولى عما إذا
كانت قد طلبت من
الدوقة أي نصيحة بشأن مقابلة الملكة ، لا ،
لم أكن مشغولًا لأنك لم تكن في تلك
الغرفة ، كنا نتحدث عن التعليم
في المساء في حفل استقبال
لقادة مجموعة السبعة ، انضمت الدوقة  زوجها ،
هذه بريطانيا تنشر قوتها الناعمة ،
تتحدث الحكومات عن هجوم سحر دبلوماسي ،
لقد انضموا إلى الملكة هناك ، ونادرًا ما
تسافر بعيدًا عن وندسور للمشاركة في الخطابات
هذه الأيام ،
لكنها سافرت بإخلاص عندما
طلبها
الوزراء أمير ويلز ودوقة
كورنوال جنبًا إلى جنب مع الملكة.
كما هو الحال بالنسبة لجميع الأحداث الكبيرة هذه
الأيام ، فقد عقد كل جزء من
عملية الانتقال الملكي طويلة الأجل تشارلز
اجتماعه العرضي الخاص حول
جهود القطاع الخاص لمعالجة
تغير المناخ قبل مؤتمر تغير المناخ التابع للأمم المتحدة
الذي سيعقد أيضًا في  المملكة المتحدة في وقت لاحق من
هذا العام
بعد الكثير من التركيز على التوترات داخل
العائلة المالكة ،
كانت هذه فرصة لأفراد العائلة المالكة
الباقين في المملكة المتحدة
لإظهار  جبهة موحدة ويؤكدون
أنفسهم على المسرح العالمي
ماكس فوستر سي إن إن